[Music]
hello i'm laura sanders senior
neuroscience writer at science news
and it's a big year here for us at
science news it's our 100th anniversary
as an independent news organization
covering science
and so to mark the occasion we're
talking with leaders in the sciences on
the big questions in their field
so i'm here with sujata gupta our social
science writer
to talk about stress and resilience
and how it affects our brains our bodies
and even our societies
we're joined today by dr huda akil
professor of neuroscience and psychiatry
and a member of the michigan
neuroscience institute at the university
of michigan in ann arbor she studies
both stress and resilience in the brain
and over her wide ranging career she's
discovered how stress in our world
affects our brains and she's also turned
up ways to counter it
dr akil thank you very much for joining
us and i'll now turn to my fellow
science news writer sujata gupta hi as
laura said i'm sujata gupta the social
sciences writer and my guest today is dr
brandon court he's a psychiatrist and
anthropologist at george washington
university and a global mental health
expert who has designed mental health
interventions to help child soldiers
reintegrate into society and nepal and
programs to reduce the stigma associated
with mental illness elsewhere in the
world
dr court thank you so much for joining
us
so i'll turn to dr aquila first
and i think you know this year this past
two years especially we've all heard
people say i'm so stressed out and we
all know what that means intuitively but
from your perspective you know what does
that mean from a neuroscience point of
view
thank you uh yeah it's great to be here
the the
stress system stress is of course a
psychological concept that we all
experience and it indicates a sense of
discomfort alarm
sometimes fear anxiety uncertainty and
it carries a lot of negative
correlations uh connotations it is also
a piece of biology that we share with
pretty much
all mammals
it's very clearly wired we have in our
body the ability to perceive the world
and encode whether something is going to
be stressful or not and then there are
biochemical consequences of this where
that encoding
of
an event in the world around us or even
within us
says pay attention this is threatening
this is important
and then
that information in the brain
goes into a final endpoint called the
hypothalamus which releases a special
hormone that then turns on a cascade of
other hormones in our body circulates in
the blood turns on a stress hormone in
the end called
cortisol in the humans and cortisol is a
chemical then that goes around all over
the body goes back to our brain and says
do something and sometimes the
information is to alert you to pay
attention uh to act to run away or to
focus or to fight that's the fight and
flight response and then eventually is
to say
stop worrying it's over
so there it's a very dynamic response
that encodes the information in a
biological way
and both encodes the beginning and the
end of it and
it's a system that you find in a dog in
a cat and a mouse and a rat and a human
you know monkey it's very nicely
conserved
thank you dr akil um so we're going to
zoom out a little from the brain to all
of society
and i'd just love to understand dr court
uh
how you define stress from a behavior
science perspective so for instance i've
seen that uh you know there's lots of
articles lately about
being more mindful practicing yoga you
know sort of sort of staying in the
moment as an individual
but your work really suggests the
importance of community to um building
resilience and i was hoping you could
explain that
yeah i would be delighted to and thank
you so much sujata and laura for the
opportunity to be here and happy 100th
anniversary to science news
um
so concepts of stress and resilience are
often thought of in terms of the
individual that something is happening
to me i am stressed out and i think
throughout the pandemic we've all heard
these messages of self-care take care of
yourself do some meditation do some
exercise try to eat right so the idea of
it's kind of this is an internal thing
happening to me and then i'm supposed to
respond to it i think of my own the
hospital where i work and they gave us
all free access to mindfulness apps
throughout the pandemic which is great
but as an anthropologist i also think
about stress and resilience as part of
systems they're part of families part of
communities part of society is part of
nations if we think ourselves in kind of
an interconnected web then that stress
that's on the system is also going to
affect me
but in terms of resilience it's really
freeing to think about that because the
idea is the system is resilient not just
the individual
i've done a lot of work as a
humanitarian practitioner in disaster
affected settings after an earthquake
after a civil war and what i've seen is
it's really the community that
determines how people respond to stress
rather than any one individual i really
loved the comment that huda made about
you know our brains telling us that the
the trauma is over the stress is over
the stress has over stopped freaking out
and that's something that occurs not
only internally with regard to our our
endocrine regulation in our brains but
we rely on our friends on our family and
our co-workers to say the same thing to
us hey you know you're through this
you've made it through that you're able
to take care of yourself so resilience
is constantly something that we're doing
inside and with everybody else around us
at the same time which is why i think
it's so important to talk about it right
now because we're in the midst of a
pandemic where in many ways we've been
cut off from those social connections
around us that help us respond to stress
and be resilient
fascinating yeah that idea of kind of
looking at this at different levels you
know you can go all the way into
the cortisol released in a certain brain
area you could zoom out to the person
and the body and then you can zoom out
to the society effects and and how we're
all interconnected it's
it's i'm curious how you two see those
levels interacting you know is there
is there
discoveries to be had at all the levels
are they interconnected how do you see
them kind of working together so if i
may uh
the question is
um
what is stressful let's think about
humans in particular for a minute and i
remember when i first started
i would try to do things to human
subjects including putting them in a
cold room or
asking them math questions and one day
my assistant said
you know the people who give us a
biological stress response
are doing it especially if they think
we're judging them
about how they're doing on their math
questions
not so much how hard the math problem is
and sort of the penny drop that they
that a lot of it is social that being
judged for example is really
biologically what's triggering the
stress system and then we started doing
studies in animals as well and we
realized how much
social interaction is a key component
of the stress system so if you think
about
the job of surviving altogether
exactly what brandon said is absolutely
critical you're not alone in the world
whether you're in the wild or in a in a
modern society and you need to take care
of whether yourself or your babies or
your property you need to
take the environment into consideration
and that includes the social environment
so social encoding
is absolutely
key
to we have entire brain systems brain
circuits that encode relationships
support
hierarchy
aggression social interactions so these
ideas are completely compatible because
the the social setting and the biology
are all part of that same survival
evolutionary
uh framework that we're all living
in
i mean it seems really
intuitive um but i think it's easy to
forget that we're social beings and i'm
curious dr court um
when we spoke earlier you mentioned that
you know the sort of therapist client
you're a psychiatrist and the therapist
client relationship is very
individual
and i'm just wondering how you began to
look at this as more of a
social
stress and resilience as more of a
social question
as a psychiatrist going through years of
training to become a good a good
therapist we always think about the
relationship of
that person who's going through distress
sitting in a room with me together and
how we talk about problems and you get
trained a lot on those skills and then
being able to teach an individual skills
to help respond to the distress in their
lives and so for most of my clinical
training that was how i review how i
thought about the idea of kind of
healing and recovery um but in terms of
my anthropological work in different
places around the world i can remember
at this point almost 25 years ago
exactly it was my first trip to southern
nepal to see how people with mental
illness
dealt with the suffering and recovered
and there i saw a small temple built in
the community there were no
psychiatrists no psychologist available
and people who were in distress some
that we might diagnose with depression
some with ptsd even some with more
severe conditions like mania and bipolar
disorder i saw them come to this temple
and spend time together to go through
rituals together to heal and process
this family members would also come from
time to time to support them and
although by no means did it kind of cure
everything it was really incredible to
see in the absence of even you know most
medications and and and supports that
way there were still ways to support
people and help them heal together and
i've seen since then really great
combinations of when you have medicines
available but you also have these great
community supports that get mobilized
conversely i've seen the the reverse
happen um in my experience working with
child soldiers what was surprising to me
is even though many of them had gone
through absolutely you know awful
traumatic events
not all of them really did poorly some
of them came back to their communities
and they did really quite well after
such awful things happening to them but
other child soldiers we saw in nepal
came back home and really suffered from
chronic debilitating post-traumatic
stress disorder
and other forms of psychological
ailments
and the difference wasn't the trauma it
was how the families schools teachers
communities religious leaders responded
to those child soldiers as they came
back home what we saw in the one
communities where they did well was lots
of support welcoming back to school
helped them restart their lives in
another community where there was not
support for them coming back
child soldiers who were
former child soldiers who were girls
were forced to sit on the floor in the
classroom some weren't even allowed back
in the schools and what we saw was that
it was actually the social ostracization
being excluded from returning to society
that really made the difference in terms
of trauma leading to psychological
distress and a really interesting kind
of historical fact is that although we
all talk about ptsd all the time now the
ptsd as a diagnosis really didn't exist
before the vietnam war it wasn't until
around 1980 when psychiatrists in their
typical manuals included ptsd in large
part based on research done with people
returning from vietnam where you had the
same process in the u.s some people they
came back to communities got a lot of
support from their families and
communities but in other places around
the us when people came back home as
soldiers they were shunned by
communities they were not allowed to
return they were they were mocked
politically and really it's that
experience that social response after
trauma that really makes an important
determination of whether trauma leads to
distress or trauma can be something that
we recover from and are resilient
to it's a really interesting idea you
know you bring up
not just the original traumatic
experience but the response afterward
and and kind of this really crucial time
element um and i wonder dr akil you've
written um this really nice perspective
on the kind of the history of
discovering the stress system and kind
of how these concepts have changed over
time
so i'm wondering if you could tell us a
little bit about that progression of our
understanding of it you know it's not
just a simple fight-or-flight
discrete event but it seems rather to be
this more kind of interactive adaptive
um concept so if we
uh step back and think about what the
job is of the brain in general you know
especially as you get to more
complicated organisms like mammals
humans
the job is to
recognize the environment cope with it
get the best out of it avoid the worst
out of it so it is really
about
perceiving remembering assessing
responding learning
so that you can evolve and even
predicting what's going to happen in the
future so you avoid the pain and agony
that job
sits really at the interface between the
individual and the world around it and
that's the physical world that's the
social world the stress system is
exactly that system it's not genes at
all it's not environment alone it's the
system
that
assesses the environment
and through evolution
we have multiple mechanisms of how to
cope
some of them are actually defensive it's
you know where you just go in a corner
and hide from threat for example
and some are more you know
exploratory like you are willing to take
a risk because it might be fun or it
might be something productive out there
and in a population
there is a distribution of people some
tend to be more conservative in the way
they interact with the world and some
might be
more extroverted interactive risk-taking
and so on and there is no right and
wrong it's good for the population at
large to have different kinds of
reactions to the world of interacting
with each other
but if the point of this whole thing
is to be constantly assessing the
environment then we can't think of it
only as an alarm system it's not just
your alarm that's sitting there doing
nothing until a horrible
like the fire
you know there's a fire or a you know an
attack it has to be monitoring and
adapting constantly
and so
i think you and we see that even the
level of monitoring changes during the
course of the day for example and in
different settings so it's a very much
alive ongoing system that does good
things as well as bad things and the
good things are this kind of very
adaptive plastic
malleable way of learning and the more
complicated
the creature
the more actually noise there is in the
system because the more unpredictable
the environment and the richer the
opportunities are
whereas if you are ultra programmed like
a monarch butterfly it's beautifully
programmed way better than we are
but then the environment can't vary by
much so you build all this kind of
elasticity plasticity adaptability into
the system but the price for that is
it's never perfect it's always
kind of
trying to catch up with what is going on
it can do that for short periods really
well and that's what we call good stress
where something happens
you learn from it you get a swift stress
response
it makes you pay attention it makes you
remember it makes you change behavior
and respond accordingly but if it keeps
going and going and going
and there is no relief either within
yourself or through your support system
then it's cumulative and the cost is
biological and very expensive and
literally changes the fabric of the
brain
and so
uh
again very highly intertwined with what
the environment is doing and time is
really important so your point about
time the points that have been made
about time the sequence of event the
duration of the vet the direction that
they're going are they cumulative are
they letting off at times are you having
time to integrate the information and
restart it all of that can be seen
most psychologically and
we know some biological correlates for
it
yeah as you were saying um
stress that goes on and on um
i had
thoughts of the pandemic and we've all
experienced this for a long long time
and i know both of you have worked with
animals um and i'd be curious if you
could you know compare
what you know from laboratory studies
you know what things do you do to the
animals to elicit a stress response and
how might that compare with what we're
all experiencing now you know you've
already touched on the the isolation um
the the long duration the
uncertainty about future you know are
there parallels you can tell us about
brendan you want to start and then i'll
follow
sure so my my direct animal research
days are along behind me i i deal with
the the bipedal human animals these days
um but but the the animal research has
really been incredible to inform how we
think about this and i really take kind
of a biocultural evolutionary
perspective so the idea of what we're
trying to understand about stress
resilience and healing we can look
across evolution not just our biological
evolution but also how cultures have
evolved and if we think about
evolutionary processes evolutions
doesn't just act on individuals it acts
on groups so we can actually see that in
especially in social mammals the
evolution of these social behaviors to
respond to stress
if we think about kind of healing one of
the best images that comes to mind are
you know the images that that jane
goodall described working with
chimpanzees of grooming behaviors that
if you look at somebody distressed in a
group a distressed you know adolescent
or distressed uh female partner or male
partner that often it's through grooming
that people would calm down that it
would that would or the chimpanzees
would calm down that that was the
behavior that formed an alliance again
they got somebody got a chimpanzee who
was distressed to calm and be able to
interact and if we look at this it
really is a behavior that can be seen
across almost all social mammals in some
way
a really interesting thing is that in
the 1990s there was a group of dutch
researchers and they were working on
creating you know rat models of ptsd and
so they would put a rat in a cage with a
quite
aggressive larger male rat and then have
the rat go back to to its original cage
and then look and see if it had a lot of
the behaviors of of ptsd
um
and what they found was that when they
were trying to to replicate this this
behavior amongst rats that they they
weren't seeing it
initially and they were saying well why
is that that not the case and what they
noticed is
typically they were taking the rats and
then putting them back with other rats
with whom they were familiar
if they took the rat had the red exposed
to that aggressive male rat and then put
that rat back alone
suddenly all those a lot of the
behaviors that we think of when we think
of ptsd avoidance hyperarousal to any
any stimuli
and even the the hypothalamic pituitary
adrenal stress response that huda was
just describing that you can recreate
all of that in in a rat model but it was
particularly in the rats who were caged
alone after a stressor that you really
saw this response
the other thing is that we can also
think about the biology of healing and
how that's
kind of evolutionary
in our past and ourselves now that
there's a whole process that happens
when we as a human being or again
amongst amongst chimps or rats or other
social mammals when we see another
member of our our species or our in
group in particular that's distressed we
also feel that stress we have our own
stress response to others in distress
when that happens we use our own
interpreter mechanisms to begin to calm
ourselves down but because we're cued to
somebody else's stress through mirror
neurons and other processes we then
engage with them we reach out we try to
help and that actually by giving support
not only does their stress reduce but
there's actually a feedback loop where
we get the kind of that warm glow that
that nice fuzzy feeling from helping
somebody else and that causes us to
repeatedly engage in that support of
other people and that's really the flow
of empathy in our species that helps us
to realize that we're not just alone
healing ourselves but we're responsible
to be healed to heal other people but
also should be receptive to being healed
by others in our families communities
and and social lives
yeah so i want to um echo some of the
things that brandon said one is that we
have an unpublished studies in animal
that shows
that effect of community not only on
uh on the kind of
isolation after the fact but even during
a stressful event
if we if we take animals that are
genetically have a tendency to be very
inhibited and very
you know passive and inhibited
and
we put them through an experience that
is negative for them
it really matters who else is in the
room with them even if they're in
separate cages and pretty separated the
same experience if they undergo it
during the experience itself alone
versus in a group
produces very different brain patterns
and very different consequences we don't
know how they're communicating through
smell
for example or through ultrasonic
vocalization but we again discovered
this by chance because
we had different studies and they were
giving us different results and we
tracked it down to the fact that whether
you're experiencing the stress alone or
in a group makes a big difference it's
not only whether also you're supported
afterwards but even during and it brings
to mind what happens if a whole group of
people experiences a traumatic event
together
versus if you're alone when you
experience it so even animals show us
that that's i think
it was very cool to discover and we
track down some of the brain circuits
that get activated
the other thing i wanted to
touch on
is this idea of healing but also of
stress and resilience in general we've
been saying those terms and
who experiences stress and how and
a lot of people
might think that being resilient is not
feeling stress or not feeling stress as
much
and i think that's one kind of
resilience
um
and but the other kind of resilience is
having counter regulatory mechanisms
to
compensate for that stress and rebalance
yourself
which i think i hear brandon kind of
referring to
in a lot of these cases like you know
being in a group feeling supported
and we've been
uh very interested in understanding
mechanisms of stress versus resilience
different mechanisms biological and
psychological behavioral both in animal
models and in human studies and in this
case these are college freshmen
and in both cases it's very clear
that
that there are genetic
biological mechanisms of resilience that
we see both in animals and in humans
but that there are
environmental mechanisms of resilience
that are pretty clearly independent
and that will more than compensate
for the genetic vulnerability so we we
have animals that are very vulnerable to
negative emotions
and we also have college freshmen who
genetically when you're looking at their
genetic load look like they're going to
be very vulnerable
and we've been studying them through the
pandemic before and through the pandemic
and looking at that interplay
between genes and environment and
depression anxiety versus resilience and
it's very
evident
that you can be very genetically
vulnerable and yet socially and
psychologically resilient
and that there are people who seem to be
very biologically resilient
and under
a normal circumstances like before the
pandemic
they sailed through a typical freshman
year
without experiencing too much distress
or anxiety or depression
but the pandemic actually would hit them
really hard
and it's as if they had not developed
some of the psychosocial tools
that people who are more vulnerable
might have
developed in order to survive
and so this idea and we see that as i
said in animal models so there's this
idea that there are multiple paths to
achieving resilience as well as multiple
ways to be vulnerable
and that
genetics is not destiny
and uh
really can more than compensate and that
even some experience
in being stressed
is actually resilience in using in a way
that you don't see if somebody never
experienced distress and then suddenly
gets hit pretty hard
that's fascinating i kind of remember
reading these articles when the pandemic
first hit from people who suffered from
sort of extreme anxiety saying
i'm actually doing okay
i've prepared for the worst
so
sort of related to that i feel like the
pandemic
is almost short-circuiting like these
coping mechanisms that we have and that
we are fortunately able to develop and
are you know like you said you know
genetics isn't destiny but i'm thinking
like social distancing this uh and a lot
of the social science literature it's
like the together apart you know and i
just i'm wondering how we can sort of
apply
these you know sort of more theoretical
findings to what we're seeing now with
sort of these
ruptures in society with the pandemic
exactly sujata so
and and um who do your your points as
well in terms of how certain college
students
responded to stressors before the
pandemic and how this has really changed
our ways of interacting with others
you know and and and to the point of
people with you know anxiety and how
might they've responded before and in
some ways it's almost epidemic was
productive protective in some ways
because they didn't have a lot of those
interactions
so i i think
in some ways actually being forced to
interact without with others and spend
time with them you think about colleges
you know college students
on a campus or us in our daily lives
dropping kids off at school and picking
them up there are all these little micro
interactions that are just reassuring um
back to huda's point about you know the
experience of a traumatic event are you
alone are you going through it with
others and so i think the way that
society was built prior to the pandemic
we went through a lot of things together
and in many ways now we've been having
to go through things alone so the
question is how do we find ways to be
able to do that um it doesn't
necessarily force us into a stressful
situation but helps us feel not so
isolated
and in my work really it's about kind of
the flow of empathy and how do we
promote the flow of empathy during
especially a humanitarian disaster like
a global pandemic
so two things have come up in our work
recently that have been really important
so one
is the recognition that particular
individuals have really been isolated
from accessing mental health care
throughout the pandemic especially
communities uh bipod communities so
black and brown communities indigenous
and other peoples of color that in many
ways those individuals had to access you
know things in person there was a loss
of that and then having to shift over to
remoteness but then the other piece was
has been a recognition
in the past year that we have a huge
disparity and who actually provides
mental health services that the us is is
40 minorities but only one out of every
10 mental health specialists is is not
white and and so how can we have people
that have shared lived experience come
from shared communities shared cultures
when our mental health professionals do
not represent the makeup of the american
public
so we've tried to find ways to actually
shift how mental health care is
delivered and shift who's delivering
mental health care so we've taken
interventions that we've used after an
earthquake in nepal or after a war in
another setting and adapted those
actually for use in new york city and
training up people who work in
community-based organizations religious
centers
other other types of community-based
bodies to be able to provide brief
psychological support so you have
someone from the same community as you
able to support you and we know that
that really promotes that flow of
empathy understanding back to huda's
point it's like we are in this together
going through these difficult situations
it's not a substitute for when a
specialist might be needed or something
like medication might be needed but it's
really important for that general level
of psychological distress that has just
escalated for all of us
but another really important piece about
trying to make sure that there's more
care and more empathy
in the world is also about our divisions
in society and stigma and discrimination
that if you look at people who are seen
as not part of your group and when they
go through suffering you don't have that
same response of kind of internalizing
their suffering and reaching out to help
them there's the this you know german
term shading freud which is you know
actually
even neurobio neurobio neurobiologically
a rather true concept where you can feel
pleasure when somebody who's not in your
social group is in pain right that
something about our evolution made that
adaptive
which means we need to find ways to
break down those group divisions and so
we've done a lot of work on this in
nepal we now are doing it in seven
countries around the world where in
particular we're trying to reduce the
stigma and discrimination related to
mental illness so we teach people living
with mental illness to tell their
stories to use photographs or video or
voice narratives to be able to share
what it's like and what they're going
through and then we play these or have
these individuals come and give give
give talks to healthcare workers who
often are stigmatizing against them and
they begin to find those connections
that idea that our lives really aren't
so far apart you have the same concerns
about your kids that i do you have your
same you enjoy the same festivals and
holidays that i do but trying to find
those connections and when you create
those connections that empathy flow
opens up so suddenly i feel your
suffering and i want to respond in a
positive way to support you so i think
the two really important things that
we're recognizing as a society now is
that one we need to have a broader much
more diverse mental health workforce to
really represent the whole array of
different forms of human uh of lived
experience amongst us as a nation and as
a society
and the second is what tools can we use
to break down barriers of stigma and
discrimination so that people are more
empathetic caring and helpful towards
one another especially when coming out
of a you know two-year-long potentially
hunger pandemic at this point
so i wanna also add something that i've
been thinking about
which is uh
i find very unusual about this pandemic
we talk about isolation which is of
course the big stressor of loneliness
isolation and so on
but to me an important question and i
wonder how we will be able to deal with
it
is how we perceive ourselves and each
other in terms of rules for example i am
a grandmother
and i
uh before the pandemic took some plan
and you know i work full-time i'm very
busy but i also took pleasure in helping
with my grandchildren to
both to connect with them
but also to take some of the load off
the back of my
you know son and daughter-in-law who
live in town
during the pandemic not allowed right
you can't play that role so not only are
parents of children
overburdened because their kids are at
home or you know being sent
home because of somebody getting sick
but
people in the community who used to be
able to help them
can't help them so that cuts both ways
actually right it cuts both because i
feel helpless
and they want to protect me but the
whole nature
of who is
capable of giving empathy has changed
and who you perceive as a potential
threat to you like a friend who comes
too close to you is can be if they're
not vaccinated or if you have if you
know somebody who's immune compromised
all of these nuances of our social
fabric
have changed so it's not just isolation
it's how we're labeling each other
as sources of anxiety a source of
people we need to protect versus people
who can be helpful
so
rules have changed
and i think it's important to recognize
that and we empower
some people
and we support other people who are
feeling like their own higher support
system
had to be lost because they're
protecting somebody else so i don't know
that we have thought this through fully
as a
society
but
it's actually quite
pervasive and i think very problematic
at multiple levels
yeah you raise a great point i know
all of us have probably gone through
those kind of reevaluations of
these are my children but they're also
unvaccinated threats to my parents right
now you know they're how do i
assess all of these various risks and
re-evaluate
how i how i see these people who have
been such a profound part of our fabric
you know what like so it changes so to
me one reason i want to surface this is
it doesn't need to get all the way
so definitely the rates of depression
and anxiety and etc are going up and we
need to deal with those but i also
run a lab with a lot of young people
young women who have children and i see
what how demanding that is and i watch
my own children with their children and
so on and it and how do we
socially support them and also
re-empower other people who used to play
roles and no longer can and i think it
would be really good for us to start
re-engaging in how we can
create new roles or we reformulate the
roles that we have in order to
evolve
that social network that has been
completely upset
one thing um
we've we've touched on a little bit but
i would love more thoughts on this idea
of kind of cultivating
control cultivating something that you
derive pleasure from that you feel
competent at that you're good at that
you enjoy
um
how does that fit in with this idea of
resiliency and how how important is that
as a concept to kind of the human psyche
or even our neurobiology you know what
does that do to our brain to have
something like that that we feel good
about
yeah i really
i really
like the point about brandon the flow of
empathy
as a positive force
i find that in neuroscience and in
psychiatry
we think
more about the bad things and not enough
about the good things
that's not a scientific term but like
you know we think about depression and
anxiety and stress and addiction and so
on and we try to take people from a
negative state to like a neutral state
and say let's see if we can get rid of
the anxiety or decrease your depression
or minimize your stress but sometimes
that's not possible
so i have this concept that i call
emotional algebra
where you can
if you have negative you just need to
counterbalance it with something
positive
and you know
the negative could be huge and the
positives that have to be small but many
maybe many of them many tiny positives
sometimes a big positive but if you
can't afford so but if you think that
you have a certain capital
of emotionality
and it's trending in a very negative way
because of circumstances
why not
try to put something into your account
that's more on the positive side and
that requires some paying attention to
the things stopping long enough
to pay attention to the things that give
you a little bit of pleasure a little
bit of joy
um and they can be about you they can be
about people around you so for example i
was telling you
it's it's been hard not to be able to
help family so i tried and
give more donation to people who are you
know in need you know since you know uh
we were quarantined and people wanted
older people to be especially careful
and so on well what what else can you
deploy so different people have
different skills that they can deploy or
different resources or whatever so
finding things that bring you joy
even even if nobody knows you're the one
who did it
but they bring you joy
that's i think really important to our
mental health and especially important
in times of high stress
and it could be cooking a good meal and
you know
giving some to the neighbor
and it could be
making a flower arrangement or
enjoying the change of colors or doing a
good deed
saying something positive to somebody on
twitter
any
i was just going to echo that and and
also
that that part of i think huda what
you're you're bringing up
and it's also something that we i think
as a field in mental health have had to
rethink
are these ideas that the the thought has
to precede the action or that the
feeling has to precede the action often
this hesitation of well i'm not going to
reach out to somebody until i feel like
i'm okay or i'm not going to go engage
in this behavior or support someone else
or do something with someone else until
i feel like i'm doing doing better
or even things that you know brought you
joy before this hesitation to engage in
those because like i'm not i'm not
feeling it yet an increasing realization
that actually it's starting these
behaviors engaging in those behaviors
especially when they involve other
people that the positive emotion that
that well-being comes from the process
of doing that rather than preceding it
and just as i talked about with that
empathy loop it's really after you've
helped somebody that that response
occurs so finding opportunities um just
as good as saying with that emotional
algebra
to be able to do things to help others
that give you some type of reward rather
than saying well i'm going to get rid of
my negatives first and then i can go out
and do positive things
throughout the pandemic and the
recognition of actually throughout our
lives a lot of those negative things are
there and we are not just the sum of
those negative things we are all those
other positive things as well
and if if you know my my work with with
people surviving with ptsd from
humanitarian conflicts soldiers
has taught me anything in many ways it's
not the focus of take my ptsd symptoms
away that's not the goal the goal is i
want to be able to help my family i want
to be able to interact with those around
me if you can give me those tools some
of those symptoms some of that distress
that's okay but i want to be able to
make a contribution in some way so i
think encouraging others around us to
make those contributions and it goes
back to one of the points that i made
earlier is
part of our role
is not just reaching you know reaching
out to others to help them but also
asking for help when we need it every
time we do that and tell somebody else
that we're in distress we're worried
we're upset we're having a hard time
we're giving somebody else an
opportunity to engage in that empathetic
interaction and that they feel better as
well so that actually asking for help is
a sign of impr is an opportunity to
improve things for everybody not just
yourself
i think that makes a lot of sense i feel
like i'm going to keep an emotional
algebra chart on our
family wall
yeah no i think i find i find using
economic economic uh terms for
affect regulation to be useful like
do i want to invest that much negative
energy this is this worth it is this
like you know it's an investment all of
this is we only have so many resources
within us how do you want to distribute
them how do you want to use them how do
you wanna and that's that's the part
that is more personal but can be
reinforced can be learned together
and uh that you know that i mean
there is the one thing i want to say is
building resilience is a lifelong
process you're not born with it
and you learn from having developed some
how to do more but you also learn from
watching others
they teach you how they survive and so
sharing those tools are really important
and then the other point about whether
it's top down or bottom up is really
important in western cultures we're very
used to say thinking
that everything comes from
to use biological terminal frontal
cortex from thought and then thought
mastery to action and to feelings
but if you do any
exercise any yoga any meditation any
breathing you understand that there is a
lot that's biological that bubbles up
and changes the state of your mind and
there is also a biology to that
a very strong biology to that and that
in turn reinterprets a lot of things so
we haven't said very much about exercise
but definitely definitely
and sleeping right and eating right and
you know everything that your mother
told you but it really does matter
especially in times of stress
it reminds me too of of dr court's point
about the grooming and the importance of
touch you know these sensory experiences
that then can calm
our bodies and our brains and
and yeah it seems like there are just so
many kind of
sensory things we might think about too
that's also some people for for some
people pets
are really important for that
reason so yeah i think i think
it
i mean it's it's been a terrible
terrible time and so many lives lost and
so many people suffering we will take us
a long time to figure out and the
pandemic of mental health is just as
huge
but i also think it might be a teachable
moment for us as humans
as modern humans about what matters most
you know and how to bring together our
understanding from the most biological
to the to the most social and
integrative and even philosophical
if we do it right we will learn
something and we'll come out of it maybe
doing better for each other
you know earlier
you talked about this idea of kind of
experiencing
stressful events might buffer you in the
future it might teach you how to handle
it it might kind of spark a little more
resilience um
will we all be better off in five years
in 10 years you know has this experience
kind of inoculated us in some way
um
is there a silver lining there this is
this is where i go back to
individual differences of how different
people are in different settings and
different conditions for some people it
would have toughened them up and when
they
they encountered something they say hey
you know i know i offended for myself
before i can manage it i know i can
survive
for others
it might have put them really close to
the edge and it won't take very much for
them to fall off or they have fallen off
the edge and because we all start in
different places
and we perceive stress differently and
we have these different modules within
us some of them biologically
uh programmed and some of them through
development and through experience and
how this has hit different people has
been different so even though in
neuroscience we try to understand the
brain the circuitry i am somebody who
really cares about differences and i
think that we need to be very respectful
and some people will get over it and you
know thrive for it and other people
would need a lot of support
and i was just gonna echo that that
there is so much diversity and i hope
that
as we come out of this and lessons
learned that we'll we'll also have more
diversity of ways that we we heal
ourselves and take care of ourselves
you know i think prior to the pandemic
being able to do therapy remotely was
kind of considered taboo and you had to
be in the same room that hugely limits
who has access to care in some way
um at the same time i think another
aspect of the the pandemic has been how
we all think about mental health i think
there was already beginning to be a
generational shift with with younger
people being more open to discuss it
but for anybody to to come out of this
pandemic and not be able to say you know
i experienced some symptoms of anxiety
or depression or even trauma in myself i
think would not be very insightful or
reflective so hopefully we're also going
to be continually opening up the doors
to more honest and frank discussions
about how we're all doing how we're all
feeling and the supports we need
and i think the other area where i hope
we really come out of this pandemic in a
changed way
is a more
[Music]
diverse
comprehensive care system that is going
to think about every american and every
person around the world in a more
holistic way showing because the
pandemic has shown us how interconnected
we all really are and i think you know
the other thing is the realization that
certain things that have been taboo in
mental health care like touch oh no you
would never touch anybody that's not
related at all just as hood is saying
and laura you brought up like that's
part of our biology so so how do we get
things like touch to be part of our
healing process because we aren't just
you know free-floating minds we all have
bodies and the bodies are big
determinant about how we're doing
psychologically so i hope these types of
changes in our in realizations will lead
to a different way that we interact with
others and and heal others going forward
and the one thing i want to add is
thinking more about children and
development and adolescence i think
uh
you know they're not just little adults
as we know and
i have no idea how some of this is being
processed by them
and
how it's all been impacting them but i
hope we have more resources for mental
health and children
and adolescents and that we learn how to
do better how to support them and
i am i am really concerned about
about how
this is going to play out
so
i think that they deserve
special attention and and i'll just make
one one final point on that and kind of
hope for that next generation as i also
think in kids that's when empathy
you know begins to be in full bloom and
it's really about cultivating that and
using that in their lives going forward
um it's it's sadly something probably we
spend a lot more time restricting our
empathy as we get older rather than
helping it grow and i think about one
moment
during the you know a couple months
early into the pandemic
kids are all at home i had a you know
have a four-year-old daughter
my wife and i were arguing as one does
when you're home with lots of little
kids in the middle of a pandemic and
four-year-olds who had learned at school
some deep breathing and mindfulness
exercises had this little pinwheel that
she would blow into whenever she was was
uh was upset the teachers had taught her
to do that and as we were having our
little bit heated discussion she walks
over with the pinwheel and holds it up
so she could already see in us
we were distressed we needed some time
and she was there to help heal us so we
got to take care of our kids and we also
need to listen and acknowledge when
they're telling us what's going on
because because they might be the best
messengers for us to be a better society
be a group that really cares about one
another
i agree i'm so impressed with so many of
them
who have been like
thinking about wearing masks because it
protects other people for doing things
like learning learning in a way that no
matter how much you say it in words when
it didn't have consequences
it kind of
you know goes past but
that i i think
you know especially in western culture
especially if the kid happens to be
lucky in a family that is not you know
living a distressed life they did not
have a realistic view of what the world
goes through
but now i think they have a better idea
because this is how what we're going
through and complaining about i mean i'm
from syria and i watched the civil war
go on and those people lived through
that and you realize the world suffers
on a regular basis and having a little
empathy towards that is not a bad thing
as long as we can maintain also
equanimity and mental health through it
if possible
that's a really beautiful sentiment i i
think so much emphasis has been on like
lost academics um
and
i think we forget sometimes that there's
this whole emotional peace and empathy
piece that maybe they've gained
something too
i don't know it's apparent myself that's
a nice reminder
so i think that is it from us is there
anything either of you want to you know
wrap up with
well i wanted to thank you and say i
really appreciated the opportunity i
like the fact that it went from
biology to society happy 100th
anniversary and
uh you know i hope this reaches some
people and helps them in some way
and thank you so much for this
opportunity it was great laura and
sujata to have this opportunity to
answer questions and who huda great
hearing from you and i think we have our
our next global mission together to have
the
biopsychosocial frame of resilience uh
for the post-pandemic world so thank you
so much for this opportunity
well if we've set up a collaboration
great
this was fascinating i i think it was
really really interesting to put
together the brain and behavior piece
laura and i don't always get to work
together so that was kind of fun too
um so thank you so much for for joining
us um and for our viewers you can learn
more about both dr court and dr akil's
work and keep up with their latest
discoveries in behavioral science and
neuroscience by visiting us at
sciencenews.org and connecting with us
on social media thanks so much for
joining us
[Music]
you